vous faites affaire s'est jamais opposé
de balades de contrats énormes et
bonjour les hommes il ya un présentateur
qui nous a mis un râteau ma fille
tarbes ah bah non mais tu te bats pour
qu'il paye ta mais cholet on n'est pas
assez bonne à ça pour toi mais ce pseudo
remords balle tout cas hier soir tu as
fait moins le malin et tonnes denisot
bitam parlé d' alice tagliatelles taf et
benoît s'en fout pas trop là tout d'un
homme est bien mieux que toi et ma fille
cg la maire d'eze
[Applaudissements]
tu avais fait des petites annonces il
est très bon et 2 très bas mais vous
étiez les meilleurs le fameux bonjour
les ondes il aux siens alors qu'elle
sait très bien qu'elle est l'actuel
laurent à la hausse déstabilisé par
michel denisot lorsqu'il évoque sa
compagne exactement michel denisot a
bien perturbé laurent delahousse selon
lui posant une question sur sa campagne
en fait c'est michel denisot était
l'invité de laurent delahousse est fait
c'est michel denisot qui a retourné la
situation dernier pour le casting du
film on n'a pas les rôles féminins
encore on va s'en occuper
le journaliste donateurs à une campagne
très jolie donc si vous avez une idée
pour trouver une actrice qui séparait
spontanéité bon moi non non non non je
jeu on va enchaîner enchaîné le blague
oui qu'est-ce que vous apporte la scène
finalement presse comprend que vous
mettez votre main sur votre menton quand
j'ai commencé l'étude comme ça chez
denisot et croiser les doigts
moi j'ai beaucoup observé michel denisot
c'est mon maître sert aucun sens comme
il veut tellement brûlés il faut mais
les élévateurs ça continue
[Applaudissements]
en plus ils auraient pu la couture
montage arrêt que s'est passé plein
direct un ca en direct madrid on touche
aux limites du système de là où ça mais
ça mais c'est en direct mais déjà vous
dire qu'il est ridicule des qui les
déstabilisent nous il ya un culte
spontanéité chez lui le jeune marcel et
vous arrêtez les beaux lui pendant que
ses fans à faire des polémiques ce
nom-là costume n'est pas c'est bien une
cravate noire est à une roue je sais ça
sans espoir mais quand vous voulez mais
vraiment je vois je trouve ronde au delà
je les trouvais ridicule en rade et
angers 2e absolument le contraire il n'y
avait aucune perfidie way aucun malaise
je trouvais le moment absolument
charmant exactement dont c'était très
vraiment touchant qui adorait ce moment
là est ce qu'on peut dire aussi que ça
n'a aucun intérêt cette discussion
non non mais là franchement à son onze
en a parlé denisot qui ont retourné sur
ammann a dit ce qu'il avait prévu avant
moi je suis pas sûr qu'il est super bien
repris après que derrière oui pas sûr
qu'un petit sud parce que les rigoles
louis laurent delahousse rire ça fait du
bien eh ben on est tombé sur jérôme
commandeur qui est pas le dernier non
plus profond c'est comme ça
la tra or di donc c'était parfait en
tout cas voilà en tout cas ça n'a pas
très bien marché il ya 1 5 million trois
cent mille téléspectateurs mais par un
faux les noirs le dimanche on part
d'audience a fait sa pub et bhl ça plus
de part d'audience accor à 7.8 20h30 qui
fonctionne plutôt bien c'est le sait le
jt et 19h le dimanche à hier qui n'a pas
fonctionné
à combien à 16.8 de part d'audience et
le score le plus faible sur la perte
d'audience et le mauvais sens qu'ils
donnent des chiffres mais je vois
d'autres chiffres